what if text prompts enabled anyone to
make any type of
movie or even an entire box
set that's the promise of
AI someone will make a movie just with
your phone that will be watched by
hundreds of millions of people so could
this become the future of the movie
making
business
in the great movie studios complicated
in the country that popularized film a
new generation of startups believe they
are laying the foundations for a massive
disruption to the movie making World let
me show you how it works I'm going to
start with a simple one which is tax to
video by using generative AI companies
like Runway can create videos in seconds
that would normally take a visual
effects artist days let's do a sky with
clouds I can choose directions on style
or cinematic choices or angles that I
want to preview I really like this one
it seems like the the light is coming
out of the clouds the AI is scking that
image and now generating a video out of
that the AI is basically able to take
that language and create consistent
realistic and accurate videos that
represent what you're writing you can
see now the clouds are moving the sky is
turning a bit dark a storm is coming
these are short clips of for second that
I've just generated the tax but I also
put them together um in a small clip so
let's see how that
looks the AI is able to predict how
objects might
move you can specify with a brush what
objects do you want to move within that
picture so in this case I will select
just the sky and you can see now the sky
is moving I can select the boat and now
the boat is going to move as well I can
select hear a person walking on the
street or the smoke from the cigarette
or how things look from different angles
in director mode you can move a camera
almost like a video game top left down
up zoom in zoom out and use that as the
starting point for any story you want to
tell the AI also allows actors to be
transformed with a click you can use it
for generating different worlds
basically any world that you want so
here I'm in my office in New York but
let's say I want to go to One Enchanted
Fantastical world so just clap my
fingers like this and I'm now using this
video plus a text prompt to transport
myself into another world I can go into
an anime
world so I can do an switch between
different universes just by using
AI Runway is one of a number of
companies hoping to make AI integral to
the future of the movie
business so how long will it be before
your local Multiplex is showing feature
films entirely generated by AI or
producing an entire High box set for a
streamer runways Founders are reluctant
to give a time frame but they believe
it's a case of when not if someone will
make a movie just with your phone that
will be watched by hundreds of millions
of people it's going to change the
landscape of film making and the
landscape of Cinema however it is still
early days for this technology in the
movie
business so far perhaps runway's most
high-profile use has been enhancing
scenes in big budget films
like the visual effects in this scene
from the Oscar winning everything
everywhere all at
[Music]
once outside the commercial mainstream
artists and filmmakers are experimenting
with shorter
films like this one about loneliness
directed by Paul
trillo what if we took different routes
and if we took our time at different
times then maybe things could have been
[Music]
different when it it comes to
Blockbusters AI may be best suited to
taking over genres like animation and
sci-fi but what about realist films such
as historical
epics generative AI has yet to master
the photorealistic video these kinds of
films
demand some of ai's output can look more
like Salvador Dary than Martin Scorsese
I do love that money
sir we're still at the very early stages
of this technology it's only a matter of
time and until you get to a point where
you won't be able to distinguish live
action from generated video using
AI with Google and meta also working on
their own text to video generators AI
could one day prove as transformative to
the movie business as sound color or
even the invention of the camera
itself the camera was one of those
moments in time where a technology and a
scientific revolution creating a new art
form we're at that work combination and
moment in time where we're about to see
a new kind of Cinema being
born of course a world where video is
made by giving text prompts to machines
is not for everyone and may sound
dystopian to some people there are fears
that AI could wipe out entire
livelihoods maybe even replace the human
stars of the screen themselves they
could take your image and do what they
want
AI but those in the business of AI argue
it could unleash new kinds of creativity
in movie making you're not going to
become a painter just by having a
paintbrush you're not going to become a
filmmaker just by having AI the core
aspect of the creative process is still
about experimentation and these tools
are tools for experimenting way faster
than ever before by making Film
Production more affordable AI could make
the business more accessible and
Democratic there could be fewer
Hollywood Neo babies and more
opportunities for
Outsiders AI will change who gets to
make movies more people out there will
have the power of perhaps what big
Hollywood Studios only have today and so
the most important change will be for me
who gets to tell stories and what kind
of stories do we get to watch and
see hi I'm Tom Wright I'm the tech and
media editor of The Economist if you'd
like to watch more about generative Ai
and entertainment business please click
on the link opposite and to watch more
of our now next series click on the
other link thanks again for watching and
please don't forget to
subscribe